[Music]
in the last year median household
incomes in the US have gone up a
record-breaking 5% Wow thanks Obama wait
a minute what was that it was me I said
thanks Obama
okay well the Census Bureau also
reported that poverty rates are falling
faster than they have in decades great
thanks a lot Obama you know I gotta be
honest you do not understand your tone
at all these are all good things I know
that's why I'm thanking him even you're
not just thinking you're being sarcastic
no it's just my regular voice but people
tell me that at work all the time what
what was that anyway where do you work
that jumbled sentence let's try it again
you're being sarcastic
it's the cue cards anyway if I was being
sarcastic then why would I wear this
shirt thanks Obama
make sure you open it all the way so we
can see the ad the quotes ya know a top
it yeah why is only thanks in quotes and
not Obama what is this a punctuation
seminar see now that sounds sarcastic no
I'm seriously asking is this a
punctuation some no it is not a
punctuation seminar it's not well then
I've made a terrible mistake Conan I'm
sorry I've taken up way too much time
away from your show and it really is one
of the finest programs on television
thank you very much sir I appreciate
that no that time I was being sarcastic
you're an [ __ ] well
[Music]
the real question is why do I just spend
40 minutes talking to anyone in the
crowd got anything to say at any time
[Laughter]
Conan he recently went on an audition
for a Steve Agee type I don't think I
got it either you didn't get it right no
no nor should you
it's you're too much of you
[Music]
you